hey guys it's max today we're gonna be
comparing apples brand-new 2020 MacBook
Air against Microsoft Surface laptop 3
and believe me this is a very tough
choice both laptops are excellent the
surface laptop 3 is one my favorite
Windows laptops this is mine I bought it
personally I'm keeping it it's excellent
not only are we going to be looking at
the CPU and graphics performance we're
also gonna test things such as speakers
the webcams and microphones the
keyboards we're also gonna look at
thermal performance once these laptops
heat up and authentication and much more
now I've links to both these down in the
video description below there are some
great deals on the surface laptop 3
which makes it a much tougher choice and
I'll talk about pricing at the end
there's also a few discounts on the new
MacBook Air now let's go ahead and get
into I'm gonna close these up right here
and let's compare the exteriors now if I
put the MacBook Air on top of the
surface laptop 3 you guys will see that
as far as width they're about the same
but the surface laptop 3 is taller or
deeper that is because the aspect ratio
of the screen is different and then as
far as thickness on the backside here
the surface laptop is a little bit
thicker and same thing with the other
side if you guys take a look over here
it's a little bit thicker and holding
both of them in the hand the surface
laptop 3 feels a little bit chunkier
it's a more edgy kind of squarish design
whereas the MacBook Air it has this nice
kind of slate shape but as far as the
actual weight they are very similar we
have 2.8 pounds for the MacBook Air and
2.8 5 pounds for this all aluminum model
of the surface laptop 3 I have this
model which is black and it is a
fingerprint magnet it is crazy whereas
the MacBook Air it resists being prints
much better even if you have the space
gray version and it just feels nicer
built over also build quality definitely
goes to the MacBook Air
as far as ports the MacBook Air has a
headphone jack and it also has two
Thunderbolt 3 ports that run at full
speed and that is all with the surface
laptop 3 on this side we have a
headphone jack we have a USB C port in
the USB a port and on the other side you
can use for the charging connector and
then taken
docks that they sell separately now this
USB C port is not vulnerable three
compatible and that's one of the biggest
downsides of the surface laptop three
now that means that with the MacBook Air
you can easily connect this to a
Thunderbolt three dock instead of a USB
C dock and I'll give you a lot more
performance a lot more capabilities and
you can plug in an external graphics
card to this laptop whereas you cannot
do that with the surface laptop three
now as I open these up I have to commend
Microsoft for doing a great job on the
hinge it is a one-handed open and as you
guys may have noticed the surface laptop
three automatically logged me in and
that is because it has Windows hello
now the MacBook Air doesn't have that I
wish it had face ID but it does have
touch ID so it works really well now
that we have both open you guys could
see that there is a difference in
displays the MacBook Air uses a sixteen
by ten display which is nicer a little
bit more vertical space but Microsoft
takes it a step further and gives us a
three by four display so it starts at
about the same point here but this one
is even taller which means that more
stuff can fit on the screen now as far
as resolution not a huge difference but
the MacBook Air is slightly sharper now
we also have some differences in terms
of brightness the surface laptop three
is actually a little bit brighter than
the MacBook Air but it doesn't have as
good coatings for reflectivity now
reason for this could be because the
surface laptop three is actually a
touchscreen so if you're somebody that
likes to have touch capability this
definitely has it now let's move down a
bit and look at the keyboards the
surface laptop three has an excellent
keyboard the keys are large they feel
really good they're not mushy and
previously in our last comparisons we're
in the Mac books had the butterfly keys
this definitely one but Apple updated
this to their new magic keyboard which
is the best of their previous two and
this one is better not buy a lot just a
little bit mostly because it's a little
bit more tactile it's a little bit more
stable gives you a little bit more
feedback and it also has really good
travel but I don't think you're gonna go
wrong with either one these laptops if
you do a lot of typing now moving down a
little bit lower this is where we see
some differences the surface laptop pari
has a really good track pad one of the
best
a Windows laptop it is quite large but
it is a click track pad meaning it's
easy to click at the bottom but if you
go higher it is much more difficult to
click whereas the MacBook uses their a
force touch trackpad which is all glass
and it doesn't actually click there's
magnets in there and that allows it to
feel completely the same no matter where
you're clicking you can actually adjust
the feedback level and tune it and that
is just so nice it definitely is a step
above this is the quality of the MacBook
Airs built in 720p webcam and
microphones and here's the quality of
the surface laptop 3 s built in 720p
webcam and microphones go ahead let me
know down in the comments section which
one looks and sounds better to you now
it's time to compare the speaker's the
MacBook Air has speakers that are user
facing through the speaker grilles over
here whereas the surface laptop 3 has
speakers that just fire through the
keyboard it seems because I can't find
any ports anywhere I just flipped my
Lavin mic to be completely even between
these two laptops you go ahead and put
on your best pair of headphones and
let's see which one is better
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
you'll let me know what you think down
in the comments section below keep in
mind I am recording through a lav mic
and this is going online but what I can
hear personally is that this is a tough
call so the surface laptop 3 is
definitely a little bit louder judging
off of my Apple watch it peaked about
one decibel louder and you can tell that
it also has a little bit more bass and
then the high frequencies all are a
little bit more kind of sharp whereas
the MacBook Pro is more balanced and the
mates have more clarity if I had to
choose one to live with I would probably
say I would rather have a little bit
more loudness even though the overall
sound quality might be a little bit
worse just because in certain
environments that can be really useful
now it's time to get into performance
both these laptops are using Intel's
latest 10 nanometer I 5 quad-core
processors 8 gigabytes of low power ddr4
memory and they both use Intel iris + g7
graphics which are a great deal at this
price point compared to a lot of the
competition so this is going to get
interesting I'm gonna go ahead and start
the CPU benchmark the MacBook Air has a
1.1 gigahertz base goes up to 3.5
compared to a 1.5 that goes up to 3.7 so
surface laptop 3 I believe it uses the u
processor and whereas the MacBook Air
uses a Y processor and that just means
that the MacBook Air is designed to save
more power be more power efficient and
we're gonna talk about battery life in
just a bit as well and here's our
results not only does the surface laptop
3 beat the MacBook Air in single core
performance by just a little bit with a
very excellent score in multi-core it's
actually about 35% more powerful and not
as pod just because of the extra wattage
that it can use for the CPU now let's go
ahead and test out graphics it looks
like the surface laptop 3 gets about a
20% higher score in terms of graphics
and I wanted to do a gaming test here
but unfortunately the surface laptop
keeps crashing my Unigine test and I
kept reinstalling it from different
websites and that's I'll talk about
Windows here and just a little bit but
let's go ahead and test out thermals a
little bit more we're going to use
Cinebench r 20 which i have open right
over here and i'm
be looking at the frequencies as well to
see what kind of a sustained load can
these laptops handle and also what about
the fans let's say run right off the bat
we get 3.5 gigahertz here and 3.6 here
it actually didn't hit 3.7 and as soon
as the test starts running we're getting
3.3 gigahertz
on the surface and we're already down to
three point or two point three on the
MacBook Air so this is throttling really
quickly the MacBook Airs fans are
already spinning up at 4,500 rpm we've
been sitting at a hundred reso seus for
a while and now we're down to 1.7
gigahertz whereas with the surface
laptop we are running at 2.7 much higher
and we're still at 77 degrees Celsius so
the the thermal performance is actually
quite good and as far as fans I cannot
here the surface laptop 3 but it could
definitely here at the MacBook Air it's
still really quiet and this is a very
quiet room here but we definitely notice
some differences so surface laptop 3 is
done with a score of 1680 really high
score two-thirds the way through with
the fans did kick up but it was still
quieter than the MacBook Air and it was
able to maintain 2.7 gigahertz
throughout the whole time and I didn't
see it hit above 80 degrees Celsius
which is impressive the MacBook Air
still has a ways to go here and we're
now running at 1.5 gigahertz and
hovering right around the hundred
Celsius mark and the results are in with
a surface laptop three scoring about 70
percent higher than the MacBook Air and
why do we have such a big difference
between Geekbench
and Cinebench well Cinebench as pushing
all the four cores to their max bricks
and a period of time and the only way
the MacBook Air can keep itself cool
enough without shutting down is by
slowing down the chip if we had better
cooling maybe there'd only be about a
15% difference instead of what we are
seeing I know a lot of you guys asked
for SSD tests so here we go we're gonna
start both of these and we're seeing a
pretty big difference
Apple's SSD in terms of write speed is a
lot faster as far as the read comparison
so the surface laptop is just a sliver
faster basically the same at 1400 but
the MacBook Air
is close to three times as fast for the
right speeds so we compared a bunch of
different areas but what about pricing
and value well the MacBook Pro
surprisingly if we're just looking at
MSRP z' is about $200 cheaper with the
same amount of RAM SSD storage and also
an i-5 quad-core processor but with that
said you can get some great deals on the
surface laptop three I'll go ahead and
have a link in the video description to
Amazon where you can get 300 bucks off
of this laptop and that brings these two
much closer together it makes us
actually a little bit cheaper now as I
mentioned it's a very tough choice with
the surface laptop 3 you're gonna have
better performance especially under
extended load for both CPU and graphics
and that could be great the screens a
little bit taller which is nice for
productivity on such a small device and
in general it is an excellent laptop
where the MacBook Air really shines is
Mac OS I definitely notice using both of
these that the MacBook Air is snappier
opening up programs web browsing
unzipping files doing downloads
everything feels snappier and I don't
have as much issues as far as crashes
and apps not working for example I
really wanted to run the unit in heaven
I could not get it to work
there's just errors like this and on top
of that we do have a difference in
battery life the MacBook Air gets about
two to three hours better battery life
and mixed uses and we also have
Thunderbolt 3 ports which allow you to
connect them EGP you if you want to do
more serious work or even doing some
gaming under windows boot camp so
because of that if you look at the kind
of the overall package I would choose
the MacBook Air but if you don't care
about operating systems and you want
better performance with the laptop
itself I would go for the surface laptop
3 there you guys go if you have any
questions let me know down in the
comment section below and click above to
subscribe if you guys want to see more
videos and if you want to see how the
MacBook Air stacks up to the MacBook Pro
you guys can click right over there this
one max and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]